this is the beginning of it
series
discussions seminars which I'm in while
sudah is chairing professor history I'm
gonna put that first and the French will
be French department and they subtly yes
mr. Mike so what we're doing tonight is
we're beginning at the series dealing
with broader questions of the European
crisis austerity political economy and I
wanted to introduce to you
Emmanuel da who will be introducing
intern market-wide I'm very very
grateful for him to be here when we
thought of the series we thought in
terms of a broader project on austerity
and here we have Marc who is actually
just come out with his book really fresh
off the press we didn't have copies of
it so forth so it's focused in on
Inauguration in the series and also they
do view of mark here back here speaking
about his book I wanted to alert you to
another of what we've actually been
working on a couple of lines here so one
thing you can come to blinkin
Institute's European Institute to find
out about his questions relating to
political economy the European crisis
and broader and deeper perspectives on
it but we've also been working on
questions related to the new diplomacy
to cultural diplomacy working with the
colleagues and journalism and tomorrow
evening in the same building at 6:15
there will be a roundtable sponsored
with the journalism school shared by
Anya Shiffrin which brings in very State
Department and other types again
contemporary and with historical
perspective on questions relating to the
new public diplomacy
I'm going to be very brief first I will
signal that there is a for the graduate
student there is a breakfast tomorrow
morning at 8:15 at deluxe only for
graduate students you don't have to
register yet just show up at daleks 8:15
you all know that the LOX is on Broadway
between 112 and 113 so we delighted
tonight to have mock blight at the the
blinkin European Institute Mark Gatiss
knows Columbia very well he received is
a PhD in political science from Columbia
in 1999 and is now after teaching at
Johns Hopkins University is now Brown
sorry so after is teaching at Johns
Hopkins is now teaching at Brown is a
professor of international political
economy at Brown University that's what
I meant
so most of his work has been on the
connections between the life of ideas
and institutional changes especially in
the economic field his first book can
you hear me this way yes yes so his
first book published in 2002 by
Cambridge University Press
great transformation economic ideas and
institutional changes in the 20th
century and it was about the connections
between ideas and institutions and after
that echo edited or edited two important
volumes that were summing up the
directions and calling up for New
Directions in the disciplines especially
the the first one I'm going to put the
word pledge and book for international
political economy
IPE at the global conversation was
published in 2009 and then he also did
another volume which was less about the
discipline and more about the
politically but economy international
economy as a field of practice and that
is a volume accredited and titled
constructing the International economy
that was published by comma University
Press in 2010 so in many ways
his letters booked just after press
austerity the idea of a dangerous ID
which you can buy just outside here is
that this intercept is at the
intersection of those several interests
since it looks at the history at the
deepest tree the long jury history of
the idea of austerity in many places in
the world and that its effects in the
form of deep incisional changes in the
international economy as some of you
know and as Dickie was just reminding us
of the blinkin European Institute under
the leadership of Victoria de Carranza
and Christopher Hill has just launched a
new initiative on the question of
austerity a word that as you all know is
very much the order of the day in Europe
and the initiative I think as for its
first and major goal the objective to
expand the kind of reflection that is
going on right now in Europe and
elsewhere in the world from a very kind
of new cycle a life in the new cycle to
a deeper into a deeper history and kind
of interdisciplinary approach to try to
understand austerity in its long jure
incarnations and also try to think about
it not only as an economic concept but
also as a cultural social concept so we
could not think of a better person than
light to start this interdisciplinary
conversation tonight and we're very
happy to have him in conversation with
professor Victoria de Gracia who doesn't
need an introduction here but still as
all you all know you know she's a
professor of history at Columbia
University she's a director of the
blinkin European Institute she's a
specialist of Italian and European
history she has produced major books on
gender on fascism on gender and fascism
in Italy
she's also devoted a lot of her work and
attention to the eye
the notion of consumer cultures and I
think in many ways she's like mark glass
has been very interested in the the
larger field of political economy in
Europe so here we have two major
contributors who are going to be in
dialogue on this issue thank you very
much oh thank you for the introduction I
think I have a clerk mic so this should
be working right that's better I'm gonna
stand up the reason I stand up as good
of a sit down agar board and so do you
because it means that you start looking
at a fixed point and when you're full
instead of looking at a fixed point your
eyes do this and you start think that
overwhelming you know the notion of
tiredness you only get in lectures it's
because you've been sitting looking at a
fixed point so we're gonna move around a
bit all right
history of a dangerous idea let's get
kicking on this one before we get to the
theories useful to know why I'm
interested in this question and this is
the intellectual argument is the
following I did a bunch of stinky
garbage mortgages in Los Angeles I end
up causing a sovereign debt crisis in
the periphery of Europe it's not exactly
intuitively obvious is it it's not like
you draw a straight line from warning or
well that obviously causes that more to
the point why is it mediated as a crisis
of government spending when in fact have
you spent for more than five minutes
looking at it it's current essentially
private sector crisis of financial
markets probably turbocharged by
derivative markets in particular has
something to do with houses but when
essentially private sector it envelops
almost all the developed world only one
of them had a funny Infiniti so you
can't really blame that for everything
that goes on in the world and then that
sort of washes up on the shores of
Europe and as I say causes a problem
with sovereign debt markets which really
have nothing to do with collateralized
mortgage obligations so working out I
was part of it another thing that I
wanted to do that was part of it was
basically exorcise some demons of my own
so why am i interested in this question
because it really really annoys me when
people say this is all about governments
who have spent too much
let's remind ourselves are some simple
facts on this one right you basically
start off with a boat through a ton of
the 2000s both 32 percent debt to GDP in
the United States so let's have a couple
of rounds of unfunded tax cuts so we're
never going to pay for themselves I'll
blow your dad up a bit then stake a
couple of wars of choice you defuse that
or pay any taxes to pay for
and you're the 61% of GDP by 2006 I
don't remember anybody screaming about
over government spending at that point
in time and then along comes the
financial sector and basically blows a
hole in financial space-time to the tune
of three or four trillion dollars that
takes you up to 80 percent of GDP then
put in the luggage that lost GDP that
comes from the heart the lack of tax
revenue the deficit ballooning etc and
you're up to a hundred percent so this
is an orgy of government spending oh
yeah it is but basically it's an orgy of
government spending on Wall Street and
asset protection for the people who
already have everything and the people
who are going to pay for that somehow
are pensioners there's something
fundamentally wrong about that but let's
get to Europe as you can see it's not in
great fiscal health it's always good to
look at the net debt to GDP figure
rather than the gross the gross is the
big scary number people like to say but
also assumes basically that there are no
taxes being paid there are no assets in
the national biology but nonetheless if
you look at it it's not too great I mean
everyone's kicking up around sort of
like 100 percent 80 percent etc you'd
rather not be there if you could at all
help her so who brought about this fine
mess as Laurel and Hardy would say that
being waddle and hardly on the left of
course
well the story that we get is as this
crisis of government and if span all
this money and now the credit bubble is
gone the markets are freaked out the
yields have gone up and now you have to
cut cut cut but there's actually a much
more interesting story again have you
bothered to look into the banking side
of this which is the bet you never
really hear so if you go back in the day
to before the Euro came in you get this
spread amongst European that bought the
the sovereign bonds of different
European countries and this reflects in
a sense the real risk in the bond I mean
you basically you're gonna get 22 to 25
percent for holding Greek debt because
it's dodgy alright when you're gonna
pull the Italian that it's 15 percent
why because basically they don't have
enough kids and 30 years from now it's
not clear that they're gonna have enough
people to actually pay back the
authority you're born when it comes to
maturity but then the Euro comes and the
euro is a wonderful thing because you
can tell the following story suddenly
we're all gonna be German we're all
gonna be inflation phobic right so all
existing rate risk is expunged because
you no longer have your own currency and
all inflation risk is expunged because
that's basically the same thing on a
domestic level and you
lock up the printing presses in
Frankfurt and you're gonna basically
born all the currency so you can't go
back to it so it's this kind of like you
know sir he caught strategy of like
burning your bridges you can't go back
once you don't know and this magically
means that all the rest that were in
these countries has been removed by this
wonderful new institution called the ECB
that's a fairy story here's what
actually happened why do you get this
bond yield convergence this is called
the yield convergence trade for those of
you who are into financial markets how
do you make money on a decline in spread
you buy lots of it and you'll lever the
hell out your balance sheet
so as the yields go down you stuff your
boots with more and more debt so you're
a bank in Germany or a bank in France
why would you hold on to nice boring
German there look at that Greek there
it's turbocharged and I've been all
gonna be in the Euro they're all going
to be German so if I'm quickly in
1992-93 grabbing the spread as it's
going down then I'm gonna make money so
if I'll ever ah I dump all my friends
that my doctor that I get as much
periphery there as I can i cram it into
my boots and my balance sheets go once
twice three times the size they normally
were and of course with all the banks
doing that's what happens as the yields
convert and we get to this halfway point
where the Euro comes and everyone says
see we have removed all of the risk
Greece who has never run a deaf ear on
never run a surplus in 50 years suddenly
has the same bond rating as the Germans
it's all gone it's all magically gone
away that's great and then of course it
stays like this because the entire world
isn't engorging itself on a wonderful
credit binge and then when the credit
bubble pops guess what all the yield
spreads come back to where you were
before now this creates a bit of a
problem if you're one of those big banks
there's been stuff on your balance sheet
filled with periphery that specifically
this is what happens it means that the
periphery day of italy portugal in spain
in 2011 was effectively 32 percent of
the gdp of france
crammed into the balance sheet of three
banks so of those debts are bad and that
bank is levered not 30 to 1 a 3% tongue
against its assets it's gone around
right illiquid if not insolvent and
given it doesn't have its own printing
press anymore
whoops it gave it to the germans you got
a bit of a problem because you can't
bill yourself oh you can't inflate your
way out of it you can't devalue your way
out of us and the only thing you've got
is what they've been doing
the past several years squeeze out
liquidity and prey otherwise known as
the t-shaped the tree shaper so France
the Netherlands Portugal Germany in the
UK are seriously hulking to a bunch of
sovereigns who managed to expand sell
all that debt to court banks because the
coal banks went on a spending spree
because it was in their interest to do
so because it was a nice way of doing a
yield convergence trade before the Euro
came in and it was free money until it
wasn't because then all the risk shows
up in the balance sheet the result is
ready for this assets held by banks in
Germany France in the UK at about double
the annual GDP of the entire EU that's
banking assets that's the tall GDP of
the European Union what happens if 10%
of those assets are crap and are never
coming back and your level to 40 to 1
that's why the Greeks can't leave
because definitely a leave it's a
trigger point and that triggered was the
Portugal and then it was from Portugal
to Ireland and Ireland is actually
setting on real terms about 170 percent
debt to GDP it's got about 45 45 billion
in the euros and a bad bank called nama
with assets that are never ever coming
back so you do a born you do a bank run
around the bond market of the European
sovereigns and where does it go it goes
back to these countries and it blows up
the core banks that's what this whole
story is about the reason we have to be
austere is we're still saving the banks
the differences the Europeans don't have
a real central bank and they don't have
Uncle Ben because uncle bank and
recently the balance sheet of the bad
box pool the assets out sticker on the
bar when she call it Maiden Lane too so
that nobody knows water is add as much
liquidity as he wants in quantitative
easing and asset swaps suppress global
yields and then basically clean and
deliver the system the ECB can't do that
it is constitutionally institutionally
and intellectually and capable of doing
so for comparison the too big to build
USA is about 61 percent of GDP in the
top five bugs so the threat of lehman
which wasn't even one of the top five
going bang was enough to send Uncle Sam
running to the monetary toolshed at
least the Brits have their own currency
it's GDP that's the offsets of the
British banking system whoops
anybody here French start crying because
basically there is French GDP and PI
Bacardi Agrico and soft Jen underwent
war for the sovereign you don't have a
printing press anymore
crdit Agricole got 10% of his bounty
and crop Spanish assets are never coming
back
not just the real estate loans run if
that goes bad it's game over for the
Euro in the chord box that's what this
is really all about all the stuff about
Greek spending too much money
nonsense all the stuff about they don't
pay taxes they spend about basically
about a few percentage points below the
median tax take of every other OECD
country this is all convenient fictions
why are we doing it because it's all
about stopping a bank run around the
border market but here's the problem
when you're then EU when you're the ECB
when you don't have the tools that
Bernanke has you can't solve a banking
problem with budget cuts you can slosh
Greek public spending to neolithic
levels and they are really trying
they have lost 30 percent of GDP in four
years the veil market it didn't do that
it's not going to do anything for salt
gains balance sheet not a damn thing
because that's where the problem
actually lies you can't run a gold
standard in a democracy we learned out
in the 1930s but you can try because
basically what you're running in the
euro is a hard money regime it's a gold
standard without gold you cannot inflate
you cannot devalue you can only deflate
all your face default it's exactly the
same principles the gold star no you
cannot solve a solvency problem with the
liquidity instrument but God blessed we
share because he tried it and then after
that god bless Mario because he's being
trying it all you do is squeeze our
liquidity and pray what's keeping the
entire banking sector afloat in Greece
and in Ireland is a thing called
emergency liquidity assistance which is
officially when I don't when the ECB
itself tells the national central bank
to go and print as much money as it
needs but kind of keep it off the books
that's actually what's been going on and
the the key lesson of the whole thing
it is a very simple one you cannot all
cut simultaneously when you reach others
trading partners on the zero bound and
expect to grow if you imagine the
economy as a fraction let's say you've
got 80% debt to GDP if your flux in a 4
over 5 now let's say that the government
spends half of GDP and it decides to cut
half of its spending so running the ups
it takes about 20 percent of GDP up so
boom massive massive cuts you've done
for over 5 into 4 over 4 on a constant
stock of DDP you've just went from 80 to
a hundred percent every single country
that's undergone an austerity program
since 2009 now has more debt rather than
less and that is including controlling
for the losses from the financial sector
and the cost of direct and indirect
bailouts it simply doesn't work
Einstein's definition of madness is
doing the same thing over and over again
and expecting different results this has
become a bit mad so why did anybody ever
think this is a good idea
I hope they call this the political
theory of an absence which immediately
makes me think this is an earlier
version of the slides because I changed
that subtitle at least Authority will
wing it right who's that John Locke
handsome fella
any resemblance is purely coincidental
the key one is his fifth chapter we have
a look at John Locke's Second City's
it's a wonderful wonderful text because
basically he invents property basically
it's all there in common God gives us
her in common but basically the problem
with spoilage so in the state of nature
we invent money that allows us to
alienate our property and that gives us
property rights and there's more than
enough for everyone so why should we
care slight problem with that when you
invent appropriation markets and money
you also invent alienation of products
and wages but the problem with this is
when you let markets do what markets do
they create incredible inequalities I'll
give you a Smith call in a minute that
outlines this one and when you do this
you have to have a market that can
police those that you have to have a
state that can police the inequalities
the market produces otherwise the people
who are on the bad end of the jail are
going to come and basically bottom your
house though so you have a problem right
away which is the liberal distrust of
the state you would can't trust the
state because any state powerful enough
to defend your property rights might
actually come after you hence the Second
Amendment and all that good stuff
however any state that you want
who'd actually defend your property
rights is going to be expensive which
means you're gonna have to pay for it
thus a dilemma is born you can't live
without it you can't live with it and
you don't want to pay for it so how do
you pay for it if you don't want to pay
any taxes and you're a good liberal
subject well what you do is you talk to
David Hume because David Hume notes the
growth of debt markets where the
sovereign in Britain around the time
that he's writing he's appalled by this
he says public credit will destroy the
nation why is that well it's a wonderful
thing about you need his essay on money
because a lot of modern macro is still
sitting in that essay the long-run
neutrality of money and various other
bits are all sitting there and a
wonderful thing he says is that
merchants are the most because of the
most excellent race of men because when
you give them money they use it better
than anyone else so that's why they
should have most of the gains so the
problem here is that they want this
state because they'll get most of the
gains so people who don't have most of
the gains we've been the majority of
people will get kind of fed up with that
so they're gonna try and take their
stuff from them so you need to call the
state in the state comes in but you
don't want to pay for this state so what
do you do ah debt what a brilliant
scholar it's a free option here's how
this works
basically you're the state you're gonna
issue a debt instrument and you're gonna
pay me money for basically lending your
money so the thing that I need to pay
for I no longer pay for you pay for it
because you're giving me the debt
instrument
brilliant what could possibly be wrong
with that well there's a slight problem
and this goes right to the heart of the
liberal version with debt if you're
gonna do this the rate of interest you
would have to offer on the dance from it
will have to be better than the rate of
return in the real economy consequently
first ever instance of crowding out so
you start to basically move money away
from the good side of the economy into
the non-productive debt sector you
become addicted to debt us you more and
more debt you have to get more and more
interest it sucks more and more of it
and this Hume says firstly in debt
ourselves then we in debt foreigners
then we in debt are children and
eventually this easing out that's easy
money including results in the death of
the nation slight problem in this
orientation of events just when you
published that essay England who had
just accumulated a huge stock of death
from the poliana quarts massively
reduced is there and went on to dominate
the world for about a hundred and
fifteen years so putting that sort of
sample error to one side let's turn to
Adam Smith
who also said that the funding the
practice of funding basically debt has
gradually enfeebled every state has
adopted it now Smith is of course one of
those wonderful people that's often
quoted and never read and if you really
get into what Smith had to say about
this stuff it's quite fascinating the
short version goes like this everything
comes from being a parsimonious
Presbyterian Calvinist Scot parsimony is
absolutely the virtue prodigy ality
spending definitely not and he goes on
at length about this in the book why
because ultimately the act of saving
automatically produces investment
jean-baptiste say Texas 50 years later
funds and to say his law now the problem
is and he recognizes this - this is the
cool I was gonna reference and he says
in book two the wealth of nations for
everybody rex man you must have 500 per
and that rex man must live every time in
fear because of the jealousy of others
and if it is not for the firm hand of
the magistrate he would not only live in
fear he would be unable to keep his
capital safe favorite quote from smith
several government insofar as a as
instituted has instituted for the
protection of the wretch against the
poor or those who have property against
those who have none that is not a karl
marx court that is adam smith he is
absolutely honest about this now here's
the thing have you gone about this state
there's gonna be effective you'll have
to pay for it again so your rights a lot
about taxes and it's interesting Adam
Smith comes out in terms of proportional
taxation yeah there's wonderful the guys
are progressive and you're like well
actually no he quickly backs away from
it because of course it would mean the
rich people would pay most of the taxes
and he's one of the rich people he
doesn't want to do that so basically
goes for a very modern solution which
more than the Republicans are fond of a
consumption tax in national sales tax on
everything except luxuries but then you
realize is that's not gonna raise enough
revenue so what are you left with you're
gonna have to do debt but once you do
that you're on that slippery slope
because if taxation isn't gonna rescue
you what does debt do it perverts
parsimony you'll no longer the Scott who
saves you have the profligate the one
who's loading up debt rather than
investing in capital and in the growth
of the economy itself so you have this
pessimism built into early liberalism
that dad has both the proximate solution
to the problem of funding
and the ultimate end of the state itself
that is the liberal neuralgia
that is why basically austerity becomes
if you will look the aspirin that you
take whenever you have the heartache the
headache of debt as it appears over time
so I call this in the book they're
producing austerity by default you have
the can't live with it can't live
without it and don't want to pay for the
problem of the state this thing is at
one time the antithesis but also the
catalyst and also the policeman that
makes the market possible and this is an
absence because it's not until you get
to the early 20th century that the state
is actually big enough to cut in terms
of having any effect on budgets but
right from the start there is that
terrible terrible fear of government
debt built into it so this liberalism's
neuralgia and the aspirin of austerity
no two handsome fellas there David
Ricardo on the left and whose wallet
somebody said it John Stuart Mill
exactly well done and basically 100 19th
century with the growth of the state and
state responsibilities building from the
factory arc set cetera you begin to get
a more interventionist form of liberal
it as a practical thing and this creates
a split than liberal economic thinking
down one truck goes Ricardo who
basically says don't like it don't want
to pay for it don't think it does
anything good the hell with it and
actually Austrian Accord a konami exfol
words are and you get Mises and Hayek in
oh nice then you get the new liberalism
which ultimately leads us from Mill
going through Hobson new house etc and
ending up with John Maynard Keynes so
there's two trucks the first truck that
becomes important the early 20th century
is who's this one Jim is and he actually
looks like that this this is not an
exaggeration it's a brilliant brilliant
picture
Joseph simple Joe Jim Peter was of
course the post-war Austrian finance
minister who used to run around in a
cottage with two concubines at any point
in time apparently who knew and
basically didn't do such a great job
over then became the chairman of the
Economics Department a Harvard
University funny how that becomes a job
for fill finance ministers and I'm not
drawing any causal links they're just
leaving up one owner and he epitomized
that sort of Austrian Ricardian
tradition which became the American
academic economic deduction in the other
20th century of what was called modern
business cycle theory which is really
the least I'd love to real
business cycle theory that people talk
about just now and the basic idea is the
economy has this long-run capital
structure and we don't really know it we
can't really see it no one can sort of
like get outside it economy to see it in
total so what you can do basically is
avoid tinkering with it at all costs but
clearly what's happened is there's being
too much of the wrong type has been
built there's been a missile allocation
of capital this is usually financed by
banks that go crazy and what you need to
do is just let the whole thing go bang
and then the clock resets and we start
again that's the standard binging pod
story I like to call it emetic economics
and there's you know you are to do it
and then you chuck the whole thing off
so that's basically one version of it
the bricks of course have their own
version of this which is actually a more
refined version of exactly the same
thing which is what you'd expect from
the state from the Brits in this one so
basically their geneticist Joan Robinson
hada in an article this for close to 50
years the doctrine of lazy figurehead
dominated the minds not of the governing
classes this came to put it but of the
financial intellectual and practical -
so this is the name of the game hands
off get on the gold standard let trade
go well why not you have the center of
the global economy
you run the gold standard you're
basically the hegemon for the whole
system it's great unfortunately World
War one comes along and you're bankrupt
but you don't want to admit that so what
do you want to do well you got a choice
you can either devalue and kick-start
your economy or you can have a very high
exchange rate go back on a gold standard
what you would need to do if you've got
lots and lots of other foreigners
holding sterling assets because if they
got a whiff that you're gonna devalue
they dump all the assets in the pond
goes to zero anyway caught between a
rock and a hard place they decide to go
back in a gold standard a high exchange
rate the result massive increase in
unemployment stagnation through the
1920s and increasing debt through the
whole period Kings are infinitely
supportive of these policy writes a
pamphlet in response to what george's
pamphlet call convoy george do it which
talks about utility of Public Works
spending in response the tragedy right
to the memorandum on certain proposals
unemployment that makes two arguments
which are exactly the same arguments
we've had before and we continue to hear
today
the first one is modernist version is
called the Ricardian equivalence if
people know that the spending now
ultimately has to be paid by tax grazers
in the future then they'll discount the
effect of the spending now so it won't
actually do anything
so investment is null and void under
spending
how much you do and the second one if
you think the Obama stimulus used to
talk about shovel-ready projects it's in
the memoranda it's the same there's just
a lack of stuff we can do despite the
fact that never really seems to be a
lack of stuff if you ever travel by an
truck but that's just me
all right so anyway that's the treasury
bill they have their own version of this
there was however another version which
is the key Indian woman what I like to
call teaching birds how to fly because
again to quote John Robinson on this one
at the very moment the Cain's was
writing about how to cure on employment
her Hitler was curing it you're writing
down the formalism after the fact you're
getting the theory but what drove it the
social demands for relief from austerity
via sin for others Hitler that were the
miners they were the working classes
this guy was a joke in 1928 before all
the money left the country when was the
asset the senior hora is swapping
indoors plant and what happens when all
the money leaves and goes by the United
States austerity as far as the eye can
see on the border and cut cut cut cut
cut and this professor sherry Berman's
book details in 1930 what was this are
Nazis sheared of the book and what was
it 31 either you remember your own stats
18% and then in 1932 thought is
something percent and then by the time
we thought he was elected is 43 percent
of the vote
people laughing a golden dawn no should
take note of this process but what
actually happens as the war
unfortunately unfolds out of the chaos
that is caused by this in part is that
there's a whole new way of thinking
about the economy and in a sense canes
or Keynesianism
or events or both overturn austerity the
first an important one is the notion of
policies of composition what's true
about one person is not true about the
system this is true for labor markets
and money markets this is why you get
paradox of thrift this is why you get
liquidity traps and this is why today in
modern version of austerity everyone
trying to say that one simply increases
the debt you can't all simultaneously
run a surplus it's impossible that was
allowed at that point in the hardware
second one investment is social it's not
based upon Ricardian expectations
it's based upon very short-sighted
myopic signals if everyone thinks that
they're not gonna make any money they
don't invest known what happens in the
future
don't make any money so you get massive
confirmation bias and not just continues
to replicate it so it's hard to get out
because in a sense you're kind of
depressed so the notion that you get to
the bottom in the cycle and it's under
email and Treasury secretary under
Hoover said the good people will come
along rottenness will be part from the
system again emetic economics and then
you will pick it up and start again
while they waited for 14 years for
people to pick it up there seem to be a
shortage of competent people and the
result of this page 104 of the general
theory was a revolution because I said
far from investment coming just from
savings as axiomatically as the Liberals
of this year consumption - it should be
- repeatedly obvious is the sole end of
economic activity and when you do that
you change the way you think about the
whole problem of austerity because of
consumption increases national income
and that's what drives real wage growth
the last thing you want to go is slush
in your budget when you're in recession
this doesn't make any sense there's also
a political message here which I think
is the one that we really forget now
democracy is asset insurance for the
rich and they're skimping on the
payments and then if you think about it
redistribution and debt is not a
pathology it's the reinsurance contract
for democracy and that kind of running
into the script of this way of thinking
Schumpeter retreats if you read
capitalism socialism democracy it's a
wonderful text he spends 80 80 pages
arguing whether or not Marx is a
business cycle theorist the nine says
who knows he never directly actually
talks about Keynes apart from in two
lines but he says that creative
destruction happens over many centuries
so the position of the economy at any
point in time could not be accurately
judged so in other words yeah things
suck but it could be worse Lord Keynes
his ideas to him were laughable what it
actually happened was that economies of
scale and plant and equipment had led to
the death of the entrepreneur and if you
really get through that book it's a
wonderful wonderful treatise because
what's driving the whole thing isn't
this emergence of a consumptive economy
of the structural transformation of the
economy it's the end of the entrepreneur
the end of bourgeois thought you and all
above all the end of the bourgeois
family it's this wonderful enormous
conservative society falls apart now if
you're going to take on someone you can
retreat into stuff like this and tell
everyone it's a morality
we'll just add ideas also all you can
actually address it directly pictures
not to address it directly so you think
it's dead not quite it's just a long
went on who's this
10 bucks for anyone who gets it
well token this is the father of
ordoliberalism see the Germans had an
interesting history and still doing this
is why they do what they're doing the
others own today little more like Japan
than they are like the u.s. they're an
export-led economy that was a late
industrialized that had a heavy role for
this state partly because they tried to
do liberalism the hunt this thing called
the founders crisis it was a huge stock
market bubble the whole thing blew up at
that point Bismarck said to hell with
this there was the martyrs of Ireland
right and yet with a very different form
of capitalism which is about suppressing
consumption and then increasing high
rates of investment poonam through
competitive funds and then exporting
your way so that your source of demand
lies outside if you have that type of
economic structure Keynes II doesn't
doesn't make any sense because all its
going to do is push up your unit labor
costs and make you less competitive so
you're not going to sell anything
so Keynes has never had a home in
Germany so after the war what happened
was the Freiburg liberals the ones who
basically weren't discredited by
association with the Nazis or at least
not too much well the guys who were able
to in a sense write the new economics
cut for Germany and they talked about
the economic Constitution the importance
of rules the notion of competition
particularly on products is what
improves things in the world and most
importantly the importance of a strong
independent central bank so that you
have price stability is the most
important thing is that remind you of
anything
maybe like the EU sound money in CBI you
crowd out Keynes locally in America you
have higher and others the AM agrees the
Austrians who don't give up who continue
to tell the story about banks and
leverage and Clara extension the
beguiling of the entrepreneur the allure
of debt and the continuing relevance of
the Benjen towards model with the one
big message whatever you do don't
intervene the nice thing about the story
is poor modern post-war economics in
this course in its Keynesian version and
also in its neoclassical version you
could do an entire graduate program
this field and never do a class and
money credit and banking money is
neutral in the long run and I say it's
just somebody else's income why would
you even care about it
the Austrians got one thing right banks
motto credit is money
it's private money and it can have
really disruptive effects in the economy
so in the financial crisis here and
everyone's looking around going what the
hell this happened there was a bunch of
people who had a ready-made story that
seemed to fit the facts quite well the
Austrians they never ever went away they
had that story down and not do not
intervene mass is a very very powerful
message particularly here so in the long
run in the macro sense you have a
standard is enable as Milton Friedman on
the left Jim Buchanan on the right
because if you think about what the
whole neoliberal shift was both in
policy and economic theory you have
monetarism and inflation rather than
full employment and growth the natural
rate hypothesis that basically says
government can't really do that much
about employment in the long run public
choice comes along and basically says
politicians are not representatives of
the people their rent seekers and
they're basically just trying to match
the thing for their own self-interest
given this democracy isn't a virtue it's
a problem in central bank independence
is the solution because the last thing
you want is the people you elect to make
choices for you and then you technophile
all this with rational expectations
efficient markets rush Ricardian
equivalence and all the less and what
you end up with is a self a calibrating
system where government has no role to
play and the notion EU would basically
do any kind of Kenzie's project it
becomes simply laughable we're back in a
pre classical world you know Croydon oak
Keynes globally and you can try this by
road-testing it take around the world
that was called structural adjustment
programs
it's an unmitigated disaster but it
would admit that you basically write a
report the IMF in 2004 that says the
problem is everybody who's subjected to
the boat through the tests they all just
didn't try hard enough that's why it
doesn't lot nothing wrong with the
theory
it just doesn't try hard enough itself
but they're in a really interesting part
of this thought it comes along when you
get to Italy because it turns out
through court Milton Friedman there's no
such thing as a free lunch well for
those of you speak Italian or Italian
English there is a free lunch if you
skip your dinner and this is the theory
of expansion or the austerity and this
actually goes back again to those old
old liberals or German or the Liberals
because they were not just German less
Luigi Einaudi and I who's one of the
first major post-war Italian politicians
and also the finance minister and chief
banker and so on and so forth basically
wrote a lot of stuff about how this
state was a tool Pathology now if I grew
up in Italy I might think that the state
with dual pathology as well let's be
fair here but not all states are
equivalent more importantly he was a big
visionary for Europe and he saw Europe
as a disciplinary device a way of
keeping state budgets in order to stop
them spending by having them all in one
common market and having one common
currency he set up the bikuni school of
Milan which was basically judge they're
sort of a public school public Virginia
public choice done even better and more
technical in Milan rather than in
Virginia and out of this come a whole
slew of PhD students the after 1970
began to occupy critical positions in
graduate programs in the United States
who then stuff IMF desks and also senior
positions here chief of them being irony
of ironies the current head of the
economics department at Harvard
Jim Peter I gave you Alice Tina know
what's going on the other side of this
story well here's the actual story now
you talk about the most important in all
this and the most important thing here
that's confident so business doesn't
invest it doesn't have confidence right
well if you learn the Keynesian side of
things you go yeah because you don't
know the future not the invest in a
recession you look to each other nobody
else is investing you don't invest and
you end up stuck in a slump yeah very
simple and not so because the cordon
unless one you have people who are very
long sighted rational expectations you
understand time and consistency problems
and all that so what it means is the
economy might be falling down in your
own videos you might not know if you
have a job next week but you really care
about government bond rates and
inflation rates and you also care about
the size of the debt keeps you up at
night seriously the technical papers
they actually make these clips now
because of that what you do is you look
for credible signals of government
expenditure cuts so when they credibly
signal to tear down the state this is a
wonderful thing because it tells you 20
years from now you'll be paying less
taxes and because you'll be paying less
taxes now in the future you turn around
ago that's brilliant I'll spend money
now in the middle of the recession when
I might not have a job next week and
then this is great or cured the
recession that is actually the argument
for the confidence theory
I'm not being facetious when you Streb
that's exactly what it says it assumes
that there's basically the debt and
politicians handling of - time
inconsistent they can't be trusted the
only thing you could do is credibly
signal to basically cut like that so
that you send a strong signal the future
income will be higher and therefore the
things we do is always cut and cut
drastically and cut back and cut in the
middle of a recession not at the boom in
the slump that is the thing we do the
cases that make this case Ireland Sweden
Canada there Martin is still in 1980s in
the book I go through all of them and I
went through the technical analysis as
well and basically they don't show any
such thing to take one example the
biggest one karna there's a good one and
actually do Canada in the book but the
Ireland is similar
Ireland's mean trading partners bread
Breton economies nine times the size of
Ireland British economy goes to an
export boom and its exchange rate gets
more expensive Ireland D values by 30%
what do you think happens they go on a
boom when they get an export-led boom
what do they do they pay about that it's
the completely Keynesian story there's
nothing to do with expectations or
anything else and that's pretty much
what happens and every single one of
those cases problem of that says it's
believed because it's useful because it
becomes basically the meme of the g20
and then it see 25 months the finance
ministers group all I see there's equal
fund brief basically is lifted chapter
and verse and written into the ECB
report from June 19 2010 it's all about
Ricardian consumers making long-sighted
decision how if we cut that now we'll
actually have more money going forward
it becomes the framework for what so
called the 2009 Vienna agreement a
fascinating little but the people didn't
really pay attention to basically if you
go back to that graph of all the bond
yields Eastern Europe is out there in
2000 the beg you repeating bond to look
at it and think these guys are going to
be in the euro one day so they're
undervalued assets if I buy them now I
get them cheap when they come in the
euro boom this is an instant capital
gain this is fabulous the people who are
running these states given the
post-communist heritage are like
whatever you want FDI openness brilliant
no controls absolutely 100 percent of
our banking sector why the hell not so
between 80 and 100 percent of the
banking sector of these countries in
Eastern Europe Latvia and Baltics
etcetera Romania and a couple others
become foreign owned along comes a
credit crisis the box turn around and
say we want our money back please
they've actually de facto private
the money supply this is not gonna end
well so basically the EC in the IMF get
together and basically use the framework
of the echo phone agreement to come
along and say here's the idea guys wait
a minute
how about this they promise to keep the
depositors money there and not move it
to Sweden so long as you guarantee the
senior bondholders of Swedish and German
banks by committing to cut the pensions
of your pensioners by 30 percent that is
why the Baltics and everybody had to do
that huge amount of a steroid in the
first place
now they get celebrated is a great case
because they bounce back you know where
they bounce back they stopped doing
austerity first do no harm if do not
intervene as a principal in the economy
it's symmetrical it doesn't just apply
to spending it applies to cuts - it
becomes the structure of periphery
bellos cuts not taxes and the result of
this is where I started the greatest
baton switch in modern history where
pensioners bill bankers for states who
have spent too much but all they did was
basically build their financial systems
or build themselves out of their stupid
choices they made over the financial
systems a decade previously but does a
reality bite we begin to see defections
from the bonus McCarney school
self-criticism and economics is real pay
attention when it starts to emerge the
IMF begins to challenge these
expansionary fiscal hypotheses and the
2012 World Economic Outlook calculates a
negative multiplier effect of government
spending is between minus 1 point 5 and
minus 1 point 7 which means for every
buck that you cut you lose one dollar
fifty to one dollar 70 that would kind
of explain like Greece and Spain are
falling off a cliff and you have 60
percent unemployment number 25 the
reality of this is a nasty austerity
politics that comes out of the aesthetic
policies beby Grillo is round one it's
really funny to basically take your
paranoid version of Stephen Colbert and
given 25% of the bull but it doesn't
stop there because you can't form a
functioning government your tactic ruts
no longer have any credibility what's
your next trick the Golden Dawn back in
the day than the ERM the European
Exchange Rate Mechanism was running the
Brett's at a joke for at least a call at
the eternal recession mechanism this is
the new erm because if you still the
same story
if you can't inflate and you can't
devalue and you don't have a proper
central bank the
only dumb thing you can do is continue
to odd liquidity squeeze and pray that's
a time-limited trick your alternative is
to raise taxes the exact opposite of
this the raising taxes in a recession is
also costly they dug themselves a very
deep hole and it's not at all clear how
they're gonna get out of it and if you
think for any moments these guys the
Rebel Alliance you know it's always the
pegs in the gypsies this one's mine the
Rebel Alliance
Romania Estonia Bulgarian Latvian
Lithuanian if the I know I saw special
effects if you think these guys are the
way for what just to remember this if
you go to the unibrow moment or data and
you look a couple Estonia for 2011 when
they were at the height of their growth
spurt 75% of the cut of the respondents
in the Eurobarometer survey said that
the congestion and the economic
conditions of the country was terrible
and 91% said it was likely to get worse
that's not exactly a sign of hopeful
expectations and the confidence fairly
doing its magic and yet sadly
it continues so to go back to the very
start and finish on this one why don't I
write this book because there's nothing
worse than watching something that you
think is really important destroying
itself the European political project
has been a tremendous success if you'd
said to somebody in 1990 that you could
extend democracy in the rule of law all
the way to the Urals with the exception
of Serbia and a few other places fill
out the one side sort of dummy the
Americans as usual sorry you would have
got long odds and yet it worked
but you had to build a monetary union on
top of it with stunningly incomplete
institutions and no political consensus
on how to extend them this is the result
particularly when you're blind to
something the Austrians knew all along
credit bubbles of dangerous and if at
the end of the day your central bank
denies they even exist or they can do
anything about them as is the case with
the Fed as was the case of the ECB you
are going to reap the whirlwind and
that's where we are now thank you
thank you for this truly an
extraordinary tour de force I wanted to
comment on a you know a couple of points
introduce some questions that regard
history but but also all that we might
have to look at to address the problem
of austerity which you've already
greatly expanded I first first of all we
just have to appreciate the strong way
that you have addressed the history of
economic thinking question which you've
addressed over time but seems to be
particularly important the way you've
set it up here that is to bring together
if you want several schools both
continental American British thinking
you know starting with the liberal
British which is you know a way one
could also start with a continent in
fairly Marx is is not here but to see in
this liberal synthesis which in the
1920s is dominated by Keynesianism
that there are different liberal
assessments at work and then in this new
crisis of Keynesianism that one gets
actually quite different ways so that
this way of seeing if you almost look
like a path dependency the annuity
creeping out the consummate form is
multi if you want in the technocratic
area but that you get then the Ordo
liberals coming out pure forms of
austerity thinking that it's more
difficult in France for all sorts of
reasons that going back to say there is
this obsession with consumption
and the commodity which makes this kind
of liberal austerity view very very
difficult to intimately embrace that
your own training coming out of
Strathclyde that the obverse of the
Keynesianism is you know comes his gains
his notions of consumption were you know
very much in some ways economistic and
there was always the problem and of what
will happen when these these workers
start guzzling and the quality of
culture goes down because people are you
know in a frenzy engaged and cheap
culture and therefore the state's going
after intervene to boost the whole level
now so I think that's terribly important
move because it means that behind this
or new consensus around austerity there
are actually very different liberal
economic visions and it might make it
much more difficult than to come out
with this new notion that is behind any
new policy and there's going to be very
deeply different inflections in the euro
area
what is spending what would be a social
democracy coming out of that what is the
relationship between consenting and
private consumption and across the
Atlantic there are very I think rather
different so you know while in Europe
it's being said that Obama is a
Keynesian okay and the Europeans have to
now act that way but then the moment
they look around it can't be alarmed
it can't be X it can't be Y it can't be
this because those are all bankrupt you
know alternatives to austerity and then
when we come and look at Obama we say
this really is you know managing the
debt which the Americans can can can do
but there is no program of you know
restructuring that bears any Works
Progress Administration any of those you
know notions of how to restructure and
how to grow in
period of vast crisis when indeed the
West doesn't have anymore the kind of
leadership the kinds of capacities to do
what it did if you want in that
Keynesian moment so now I had a couple
of sort of questions - I mean points of
history if you want to to ask you about
I mean one is this Keynesian moment
which in some ways he's already
formulating it coming out of the Great
War that the office there is an opposite
to austerity and I think you're
absolutely right to say this is not
about you know equity
it's not about inequality in itself it's
necessity constrained by labor struggles
constrained by the I pushed by the idea
very idea of rationing during the war
which increased levels of consumption
absurdly but that was so and it was you
know question that that of indeed how
you would grow capitalism again so this
is this project and then you know it's
implicit in your work there a huge
amount of struggles which had to take
place keynes
says loud and clear in 1919 that you
know the cake of you know consumption
can't be cut in the way it's been it's
got to be now grown the you know the
kingdom of consumption we can't keep you
know recutting
a very very very very small cake and he
has you know clearly germany is very
deep in his mind in people who raided to
him they're also very deeply concerned
about the structure of europe that it's
divided so sharply between a periphery
which doesn't consume a rural which
doesn't consume an imperial structure
which is so structured in you know such
that you it can't grow because of the
barriers because of the structure of
markets the experiments well I'm not I
don't think that no
see ISM as a Keynesian experiment but
that is so there is a whole range and in
effect none of them work within Europe
maybe maybe they may be the Popular
Front works all said and done but in any
case did the French anomaly so it's not
till there's a major shift in the global
reader vision of labour with the United
States that you could get the embrace of
Keynesianism even though it's not really
Keynesianism
right so this one question is how long
is this going to take I mean in other
words the problem of the sort of the
trajectory that this is not just policy
you say do we need class stroke
I mean does are you talking about it's
gonna have to be social struggle that
coalition's you know what are the forces
that in some sense the political force
is the political engagements and in
other words saving Europe is not a
policy solution here though it may be a
maybe in effect the second moment might
you might want to bring back that 1992
that your first the bond question the
slide the very beginning just just is
it's almost more of memnon ik device
because I'm not using the specifics but
if you yeah it's it's fascinating and it
it's a question yeah there it is
so this whole question you know say that
you've got now this question of the
spreads and then you're going to get the
convergence and then the euro in some
sense is going to be their key comes
back so why is behind the euro I mean
nobody was saying you know doesn't work
does this it does that but if you go
back to look at the moment of the euro
there were so many if you want notions
of political economy which merged into
it and it was also a moment when to get
into it required enormous amounts of
deflation which were especially felt in
the periphery
and then as you're remarking then get
compensated for by credit and so on that
this is another part of your argument so
we can think of this enormous historical
moment that clearly so much goes in to
creating abundance if you want to say
that's the alternative and I don't we do
but and at the same time this moment of
entering into the age of austerity may
have a powerful prehistory in the period
of the 90s that's not only about
financial capital but it's already
setting limits and also incentives to
say okay if we want Europeans to be
equal and united they better all have
the same standard of living you cannot
have Greeks who don't have telephones or
computers or who look raggy
or have rotten teeth you know who are
you know for all the qualities that we
used to associate with with class and
social differences and so that becomes a
virtue we so I'm wondering if you can in
other words at the same time as you know
we think you know if if you've got
austerity what would be the new
abundance what would be the qualities of
it at the same time before the austerity
let's say which you have as a in the
sense of sort of a finance policy
connected to finance capitalism is there
a whole set of sort of social a more
general reader vision of global labor
that's beginning which underlies it so
nice small questions that I will be
brief so we can bring in questions what
lies behind the Euro that I like to
think that psychoanalysis is a wonderful
way of looking at this there's a term in
psychoanalysis called the fantastical
object so if you think of the market
utopia the fantastical object is
something which is there only in theory
but itself its presence is just a thing
which is like an attractor it has to be
there is the next
that a little while ago interviewed
Gerhard schrder and I asked him I said
what were you thinking about me
seriously the Greeks started on a budget
surplus you know a balanced budget 50
years what do you do he said well you
know first of all it wasn't my project
it was handed to me second thing was the
Bundesbank were screaming blue mana they
wanted nothing to do with it but they
knew that they had to do it so they
wrote a constitution they hoped everyone
would reject and they ended up signing
it and then the third thing that made it
crazy was we let the Greeks in anyway
and we knew the Italians were cooking
the books in the whole lot because at
the end of the day none of us really saw
as an economic project we thought it was
a political project it's not it's a
hugely consequential set of economic
institutions and decisions which now
have come home to roost so the political
classes that were in charge of it
basically had no idea what they were
doing that's what was behind the Euro
now would they have been better if
they'd been advised by a team of
economists he'll know the way the
monetary or doesn't political orders
emerge is evolutionary over periods of
time with trial and error with
redundancies the worst thing about the
EMU is opposed to the European political
project the European political project
is kind of an open-ended contract you
deal with stuff as it comes up you see
what happens you talk to each other it's
based upon trust you do something else a
song for you just so you know
disaggregated trust in a sense so what
is the European monetary union based
upon moral hazard everybody's out to
stoop everybody else and you can't trust
anyone the only thing you can do is have
rules and everybody has to obey them
even though you know they won't and you
know that right from the start but think
about this is a Hayekian problem right
Hayek often gets the blame for being the
guy who reels against social democracy
in the planner you can think about
eeehm use Hayekian madness because the
idea is regardless of where you are in
the global division of labor regardless
of your social formations and classes
regardless of what you produce and how
you do it you will have a 60% debt to
GDP ratio you will have low inflation
and if we just parameterize the system
in this way in a sense I don't need to
know what the future will bring because
it will be within this nice little
probability space that I've carved
though by everybody adhering to the same
rules that is insane and that's what was
really behind the Euro very briefly in
terms of you know what are the political
forces involved
time's Otto doesn't flow backwards we're
not going back to Keynesianism it
doesn't work like that
if you want to look at the one well look
at the world just 9th look at in three
segments there's basically the highly
the vertically integrated Asian global
value chain which basically produces
using FDI and domestic carbonyl they
exports the to consumption centers
that's Europe and then the United States
one of those consumption centers has
decided to stop consuming well this
obviously gonna be repercussions for
that and then the other one basically is
saving itself only because its
government doesn't work because if a
dead walk it would probably join in with
the Europeans so if you think about the
world as sort of these disaggregated
production and consumption centers it's
no longer about national capitalism's or
people you know struggling for domestic
labor or social justice all of that goes
on but it's happening at a level far far
above that and beyond the notion even of
financialization i'm quite correct in
that sense so i mean i i don't actually
see the sort of the traditional story of
social forces grappling with the
domestic economy as actually having any
analytic process and what's going on at
the moment subtly this is a near die
which technocratic could team but
unfortunately i like to put it there
epistemic hubris is dog as a hellhole hi
mark hello Joe
how much of the European story we told
Suki by your last sentence which is that
you've got a disparity because there
were no institutions in place to do
anything else right you yourself said so
they couldn't do much else there was no
institutions political institutions
capable of responding even in the
minimal way the United States so all of
that intellectual history interesting
but unnecessary right because there were
no institutions there to implement and
right that the Germans are among the
most Pro political integration of the
Europeans and so they are more in favor
of putting in place putting in place
political institutions that might my
company responded to the crisis the
Europeans of dawn
any part of the problem is is that
Germans don't care about Greeks the way
they care about their home citizens just
like Swedes and Dutch who would never
cut their own policies towards their
citizens in the way that they're very
happy with southern now here's why I
would say that's absolutely true but ask
another prior question which is what are
the ideas that are informing the
institutional designs the institutional
design of the EU is deeply ordoliberal a
competition authority that basically
issues edicts that there's lots and lots
of stuff and a central bank that
guarantees price stability or braless
that's basically if you look at the
ideas for fiscal integration that are
going forward it's based upon notions of
the shooting Clemson the debt break so
that everybody is gonna run a surplus at
once right okay that's just painting
nonsense that can't actually work in
practice as Martin wolf put it
beautifully who we are going to export
to Martians who are we gonna run a
surplus against so there's a very very
powerful ideological calling you there
is deeply imbued whether I think an
order liberal spirit then there is the
architecture and design of the European
project and it wasn't one of people said
let's consciously say it kind of became
that because in the sense they were the
people building them because nobody else
was doing it and it didn't matter so
long as there were huge colossal credit
flows basically covering everything up
it only marred once that disappeared and
that's when it became not a problem of
like if they had the right institutions
if they could build any institutions
they wanted tomorrow they would build
stupid institutions they would build
institutions that would make the problem
worse that's why the ideas of them
formed
so I questioned about intellectual
origins but particularly the way you
associate the austerity it's one of the
sources they like to take credit for the
social market economy they like to take
credit for Germany's combination
extensive so it's not just the sort of
convenient way it's a stunning
revisionist history here's what actually
happened there's a wonderful
dissertation that was render the EU I
last year and I know this because I was
on the committee and it's by a German
fair young German scholar was called the
religious origins of the Italian and
German welfare states and there's an a
wonderful symmetry that goes on here so
basically if you go back to why it is
that Germany has the world's first
welfare state when you're dealing with
Bismarck it's always been a bit of a
puzzle right well it's about basically
breaking the bark of the socialist right
well he could have done a deal with a
socialist there was lots of moves in the
parliament to actually do a deal with
socialist some of the circles really
wanted to do a deal but he decided to
deal with deal with the conflicts and
when you're dealing a deal with the
conflicts you basically have to deal
with people and cyclical and organic
conceptions of society and so on and so
forth another cloth conceptions were
less threatening to carbonyl no
interesting thing what happens in 1945
everybody knows but nobody thinks about
all the Protestants leave they end up in
the GDR and what happens in 1945 is the
Walter oaken tide coming up Freiburg
they don't want any welfare state at all
saying all right I want any of this
stuff we're going to be good liberals
finally we're gonna be good liberals
well how does the Americans say them I
don't think you should do that because
the Americans running the place are all
new dealers and the other ones who say
you should have active labor market
policies so the Walter I can and and and
these guys basically Vashta Nerada the
whole sort of the thing is going to have
a fleeing price controls etc it runs
into a brick wall when the Korea war but
Korean war kicks off and the German
economy goes into a very steep slump and
first thing in 51 and
that point the Americans good no no no
no no no no no you're building a welfare
state and you build one know what that's
what actually happened no here's an
interesting little twist I'd never
actually see as a scholar but I'll say
anyway because I'm here what happens in
1990 the Protestants come back hello
Angola have a look at German Family
Policy no it's not very Catholic
it's very individualist it's all about
keeping mama at the labor market once
again but for very different reasons so
I don't buy that story right might be
some confusion here cause and effect I
mean that you know that this the sense
of spaces are opened up in in in crisis
there there is a kind of path trajectory
that that is out of what seemed like a
certain kind of unity Western society of
abundance Keynesianism with all sorts of
inflections differences certainly in the
nature of the welfare state and it's its
origins I you know I think that we we
know a lot about sometimes some have
more Catholics I'm you know there are
all sorts of combinations and
permutations and sherry and others have
dealt with now if you start to move into
another moment let's say this austerity
moment and I think you're you saying
okay this is not simply the you know
financialization the fiscal you could
expect that there are whole sets of ways
of legitimating it and that you know
then I can say okay then the religiosity
you know comes in a Protestant
inflection and a Margaret Thatcher type
inflection I know yeah but you know that
we don't want to say that you know then
you know go back I think we're going to
see a huge proliferation of different
ways of of managing this and and of
legitimating it and that and that seems
to be you know an area that we're going
to have to go and just anecdotally about
during the Prodi moment that is in the
90s when there was a lot of
deflating in Italy - in order to get in
remember colleagues we're talking about
their their children especially the male
children coming out of the 90s we're
having a lot of time trouble getting
wives having children finding jobs and
we began to joke about this sort of the
new Franciscan ISM you know the new
movements of sort of the st. Francis
types that is of young people who you
know we're kind of moving around looking
for a cause and you know now when thinks
of you know that are new the new pope
francis and you know kind of
legitimating of a new kind of austerity
or you know sort of alternatives to the
the mass consumption but you know one
can expect them in this that there's
going to be that how do you really
jitter make a new notion of middle class
in other words both going you know
continuing the crisis Terre t model it's
going to involve enormous kinds of
leverage ideological leverage and one
would expect it's going to be fairly
local but but
ditto this other you know way you know
in other words how does one legitimate a
new kind of political economy which is
the alternative and that's
thank you question that can you speak
into the front of the mic in case of of
of imposing austerity on Club Med or the
pigs or whatever you want to call them
you see a confluence of both bad ideas
and interests there are some powerful
interests well but when it comes to why
doesn't one very obvious question why
does the Germany reflect that seems to
be is that purely bad ideas there or
there some interests were also against
German reflection what are those
interests oh parcel yes part of it is if
you don't have the German banking slide
out there but I mean a part of the book
was basically getting trying to work out
the outsole operational leverage of
different European banks they don't
publish their stuff you don't have to
like work it out in many cases and
Deutsche Bank is 86 percent of German
GDP one bank and it turns out that
there's now a lawsuit going through the
courts here in the United States because
they were bossed in the crisis and they
just lied they just flat-out lied about
the derivatives book they held it in the
bank at the trading book and refused to
move it to the banking book even though
it was a bar so they couldn't
acknowledge the loss so there's
tremendous political power here involved
because if Deutsche Bank goes bang so
does the German economy I mean it's game
over so they'll do anything to stop this
now let me be sympathetic to the
gentleman point of view the big problem
German is always hard and it's a new
version of sort of the German problem in
a way is they're not big enough to be a
financial superpower but they're too big
to be everyone's neighbor and they
actually run an operating model which is
a bit like Switzerland so it's the ones
only possible because everyone else is
not Switzerland you need to have one
person one place you can hide your
assets because the assets are generated
somewhere else well Germany basically is
kind of like a local version of China it
imports other people's incomes gets
demand from outside the Union and then
basically sells them their own debt back
to themselves and it's not of a Chinese
sort of thing with Treasury bills a very
similar thing so when you are in that
position you can't fix this problem
unilaterally so this creates a real
problem for them because what we might
be make sense is to leave
but if they leave that it's real
exchange rate bomb right through the
roof in the export model gets clobbered
and nobody wants to take the political
head for this so this is a prison for
the Germans as much as it is for anybody
else now the solution that they have and
yet the weak talk about the Sherry's
point the weakness in the solution that
they have I think you see this with some
very interesting policy decisions the
Germans have made in the wake of the
Fukushima incident they decided they
were done with nuclear power and if you
follow the internal discussion on us
although wasn't that much of it the
cross-party consensus was just we're all
gonna do this it's done there's nobody
argue number but what was filtering
through was a kind of a one-way bet on
the future which was we are actually not
crazy people we believe in global
warming and we know that we have the
smartest engineers on the planet so if
we basically get our minds together and
do this we can figure out Green Tech
because if anybody's going to do it's
going to be us and if we do it we can
print money for the next 150 years we
can sell it to China evidence because
the Americans aren't going to do it they
don't believe in the dumb thing so this
is sort of the discourse in the engineer
so they're going to do this thing now
here's the problem you then but have
this crazy idea of a debt break which
means that you can't do the loss leading
investments that you would need because
debt is an investment in the future to
actually make those types of
technologies even remotely possible so
they've decided they're going to cancel
nuclear power sign up to 30 years of
extra dependence on the Russians and
then they go to somehow innovate with
absolutely no loss leading capital
budget to do so because the government
can't run any debts of deficits that's
why their ideas behind their
institutions are stupid so that's how I
think about the problem they're caught
between a rock and a hard place of their
own making and they don't know how to
get out of it actually just at this
point of the relationship between ideas
and institutions that immanuel flag in
your introduction i was wondering i mean
you sort necessarily had to be very fast
in your presentation if recovering two
hundred fifty years and half and half an
hour but if you could reflect because
we're going so quickly you almost got
the impression at least
in the audience of economists sort of
just as these mouthpieces for this
political economical lead at its
stupidest and I was wondering if you
could reflect more on the specific
causal mechanism that you see here like
connecting ideas and institutions and
then against or that's an incredibly
broad question and another broad
question but slightly smaller you also
at least again I kind of got the sense
of your presentation sort of like a
steady and very significant influence of
economists over policy from say like
Hume onward and I was wondering if you
could reflect more on the specific role
of economist and their influence over
policy like especially arguably right
there being like a huge change in the
20th century if you could just tease
that out a little bit we had something
because we have actually very little
time and it's not exactly the same thing
but it's about the the the the
connections between ideas and and and
and political debates and crisis and
something that's rather peripheral
wasn't the presentation in the book but
I'd like to hear more about the you know
the the connections between the crisis
of democracy and austerity and the
consequences of austerity you have that
obviously in Germany but he also had
that in France in the 1920s and early
30s with you know the consequence of the
go back to the home point cafe and all
that and and you hear that nowadays or
is that intelli your that in France like
you know that that there is a crisis of
democracy as you know generated and you
know mediated through scandals through
you know through financial scandals but
it's very much there so another way of
you know maybe adding a year of
complexity to the mechanisms there's a
terrible tendency among social
scientists to be obsessed with monel
causal explanations that there's one
thing that explains other things this
thing better than other things when in
fact the world is desperately multi
causal so you know you don't really have
to choose between institutional and
ideological exploration because you know
you just asked a simple question where
do you get your institutions from it
might be from the way you think about
the problem so let me try and pull all
of that together with sort of three
brief sets of comments one of the things
I learned during the
doing the research on this book was a
read body I shouldn Greene's golden
feathers thoroughly we all read in grad
school I read it thoroughly and he
really doesn't develop the point but
there's a fantastically important
insight in that book that inflation's
are not caused by money printing money
printing is caused by the failure of a
political system and when you basically
have two sides that can't agree on who
pays the bills
you start with deficits you end up with
more debt and eventually you end up with
basically trying to burn your way out of
it and it ends up badly and that sort of
that this style of story so what's the
relationship then to go to this first
point also to this point between sort of
ideas in crisis and causation the whole
thing I think two stories are
simultaneously true the first one is the
world is unbelievably complex and opaque
it's worse than not it's deeply
uncertain what creates stability in the
world or everything that we put in it
whether those things are central bucks
birthday parties bar mitzvahs or Wars
there are this social stuff that makes
the world hang together and we think
these things are sort of hard material
things but they're not the crack under
pressure a lot easier than we think and
you crack a lot more often than we do
and we have multiple stories about how
they work and each of them is kind of
grabbing a bit of the element the
elephants are this big now how do
economic narratives get privileged in
this because they basically have this
status have been scientific truths they
pretend to be a correspondence theory of
an invariant world of maps on a lot
world non probabilistically but
basically as an actual true reflection
of the underlying physical structure of
the world and the laws the government
and sometimes that might be true but the
world evolves its entropic it's open its
non run its ad random it moves off in
weird directions and what you end up
with in a wonderful example this is
golden Browns
Premiership along with 20 blue is you do
end up with it's all to two things are
simultaneously true you need economic
ideas to basically decode the
environment and build institutions and
act on it and that gives you the
stability in the world but there are
also the things that fragile eyes the
world because you have Gordon Brown
talking about prudence prudence fiscal
responsibility prudence blah prove God
to be prudent so this goes on for years
they basically get a confirmation bias
because the economy is going up house
prices are going up labels being
reelected prudence prudence more prisons
so you just keep seeing this thing over
and over again and it kind of
so under the reality what's actually
happening is a colossal housing bubble
and a massive financialization of
British economy so the reality in theory
which may have been here at one point
start to do this and then what happens
is you have a convex that he built into
this the basically things look stable
things look stable think of trap and all
it takes is that one thing to push it
over
could be the nationalization of Northern
Rock could be American markers whatever
and suddenly prudence with a purpose
just doesn't believable anymore because
what he's been doing for the past decade
is teaching birds how to fly people have
been doing it and you've been telling
the story of a hierarchs and because it
matches the reality we kind of believe
it but it actually doesn't cause it the
causal chains are completely different
so simultaneously you can have ideas as
desperately important in terms of the
way we interact there are interface with
the world because they privileged some
forms of knowledge and a way that we
detail our interactions or our practices
but at the same time there can be utter
fairy stories and fabrications which we
treat as totems which can be completely
wrong which we can happily live in until
the world swaps us and that's how I
think those two things happen
simultaneously and you might say well
that's completely contradictory
professor blog because you can't have a
and not a simultaneous ly well you can
and be an L we are not one of a kind and
we live in a world where it ain't the
same thing there's lots of ain't the
same things out though
thanks so much I left your talk thinking
that you were suggesting that maybe the
the ACB should have the same level of
flexibility that Bernanke has can you
talk a little bit about some solutions
some suggestions to Lois fitness in
context why do we have central bank's no
but originally in many cases still our
first national boxing example there's
private corporations and they're there
basically for one purpose to make sure
that somebody has the monopoly is you've
script because that's a very very
important political resource and it
shouldn't be controlled that's
ultimately why they're now we have a
weird system going on in both Europe in
the United States here where none of the
fiscal institutions actually work the
Europeans forgot to build them they
thought the world unnecessary because if
everybody obeys the rules
Paul DeGraw has a wonderful line about
this it says so long as everyone
scrupulously obeys the fire code there's
no need for a fire brigade
right I mean and that's really where
that kind of logic leads on the other
hand what you have here is the fiscal
system Congress which is utterly broken
right and you can't get a damn thing
through it consequently what's happened
is the monetary authority which really
can't and shouldn't really try to do
that much has had to do everything so I
actually don't think it's costless to
take on the entire debt of the American
banking system and Dumbo and the Fed's
balance sheet
I think it's potentially highly
dangerous I don't think that people who
are unelected should have the rights to
do that in the first place that as a
democratic political function and yet
the people we charged with doing this
are too busy debating whether we should
have done control over magazines rather
than anything to do with listen - don't
believe in global warming so you've got
a bunch of people who are relatively
reasonable most of the time who forgot
to build institutions and you got a
bunch of people who couldn't be quite
unreasonable who love institution it was
a design not to work that's why you have
the division of powers consequently
we've got two giant central banks one of
which was meant to do nothing but
fighting inflation which ended in 1924
for the rest of eternity and another one
who is a dual mandate which if you think
about it's completely contradictory so
as a quantitation bar area and both of
these institutions are men effects the
crisis there are other institutions are
many be there to do so if there's a
lesson
as the lesson is profoundly negative Ben
may have done a marvelous job
recapitalizing the banking system and D
levering and all the rest of it let's
not forget the cost if you go to the
website of battered markets dork who is
a lobbying firm who basically lobbies
for financial reform and it's funded
interestingly by incite us who made a
lot of money off of things like raping
commodity markets and I'm talking
billions and this is their guilt project
they're basically telling Congress how
we really make money and you should stop
us doing that's a guy called Mike
masters who involvement
guess what Congress doesn't want to know
so they did their own independent order
of how much the crisis cost and in the
lost GDP in the whole nine yards
there are estimates thirteen trillion
dollars it's as big as the debt so Ben's
actions have not been costless and
that's the success story so the lessons
are profoundly negative I'm afraid the
flexibility is useful in the short term
but it's costly because monetary
institutions should not perform fiscal
functions democratically elected
representatives should actually
discharged on Monday raise taxes cut
spending whatever as we decide to do as
a democracy and stick by the contract
instead of which they're judging they're
dodging your day job and passing off to
the central bank which the central bank
is ill-equipped to do and not as
dangerous right in the top but you speak
right in the top a lot huh
thanks there we go so you told a story
about sort of the failure of both a
currency union and sort of domestic
institutions and trying to combat
inflation not trying to combat the
entire monetary crisis and then the
imposition of austerity but earlier on
you had mentioned that so that the whole
notion of social struggle domestic
political struggle being sort of a
corrective to the issue is kind of
problematic given how production and
consumption have been disaggregated and
that's the story I kind of want to press
you on because the story we're always
fed is even if we sort of abandon
austerity
try and inflate our way out of the
crisis we've had you know immense
structural changes in in Western
economies to the point that there won't
be jobs mm-hm and I mean I'm just
curious what you think about the
validity of that story because you know
I have a lot of friends who don't get
jobs no and how do you deal with that
because that seems to be the long-term
issue about prosperity that is
absolutely a long time I see let me ask
you a question do you believe in global
development are you willing to pay for
because it necessarily means wage cuts
in the core that's the dirty little
secret this dirty little secret number
two you don't need everybody to work
when you have an economy globally they
can produce super abundance you have a
distributional problem and the
distributional problem is against
something that the democratically
elected representatives amenadiel within
this singularly refused to do it they'll
give you more student loans so that
you're more and dad rather than deal
with the actual things they need to deal
with so there are some really
significant problems but let's not be
too pessimistic I am Scottish I know but
let's try and lighten a little bit it's
why do I live here I live in United
States for a couple of reasons number
one I grew up in Scotland as you can
tell and when you're not employed in
Scotland you turn around and this is
very fact that I love me god rest her
soul and in the following sense if
you're not employed is the government's
fault in the United States you don't
employ it's your fault that creates a
tremendous flexibility that you don't
have and that's often seen as a good
thing and to sound an extended of this
but what if there are actually no jobs
you can of all the flexibility you want
you won't create a particular if you're
constraining consumption at the same
time and some effort to pay back debt
misguided or guided or whatever you've
got a big problem then so what's the
happy story the happy story is this the
United States manages to actually do
well despite its government it's still
despite anybody here does IR and
political science anybody here studied I
on the whole field was founded on the
idea of America was in decline in the
1970s remember the film Rising Sun
anybody ever seen not particularly a
racist piece of nonsense well that was
when Japan was gonna run over him the
released the film and Japan went into a
15-year recession not only of them enemy
of the month is China and then he always
nonsense about China
owns the USA and completely the other
story we've heard the best deal ever
it's basically a free option on the
Chinese investment vehicle basically
they send us televisions and we send
them bits of paper bearing two percent
and there's no way for them to get over
and Congress wants to accuse them have
been a currency manipulator and end this
relationship this is utterly moronic so
it's good to be the king and a nice
thing about being the king and having an
economy which is robust to the shocks of
it's idiotic political class is that it
does bounce back when left the Lord and
it will bounce back the United States is
already growing they'll be fits and
starts but it will be back up and the
thing that growth that cures that better
than anything else actually isn't
inflation it's growth and a little
inflation and eventually that big
financial sector that caused a lot of
problems not shrinking that's gonna be
half the size of us aren't you still got
better terms of startups and
technological innovation the whole law
Germans calculus and engineering but not
much else we decry American
manufacturing we say oh it's only eleven
percent of the economy that's about 1.3
trillion dollars which is about half
your average European countries GDP not
to be sniffed up so there are huge
structural changes there are huge
structural problems but I would rather
face them in this country than any other
country please buy the book otherwise my
children will starve